in diesem waldstück in potsdam ist eine
23-jährige ein furchtbares martyrium
nachts um zwei ist sie auf dem weg nach
hause als sie im neubaugebiet am
schlaatz plötzlich von zwei männern
attackiert wird die männer zerren sie in
eine grünanlage und ziehen sie dort
komplett aus einer von ihnen
vergewaltigt die junge frau ein zweiter
hält sie dabei fest der dritte film mit
dem handy
die mutter des opfers sprach nun mit
bild meine tochter ist total
traumatisiert sie sagt sie wisse nicht
ob das zehn minuten waren zwanzig oder
dreißig oder länger es ist eher wie eine
ewigkeit vorgekommen
meine tochter ist nicht mehr die die sie
war völlig verängstigt völlig kaputt
innerlich zerbrochen
die täter können fliehen im
polizeibericht werden sie als
südländisch beschrieben mit dunklem
mundschutz
zwei von ihnen seien etwa 1 meter 75
groß einer 1 meter 85
nur anderthalb stunden später der
nächste fall um 338 wird eine 22 jährige
am s bahnhof griebnitzsee angegriffen
ein mann reist sie auf den boden und
greift den schambereich doch sie wehrt
sich mit allen kräften und kann den
angreifer in die flucht schlagen und mir
nun zugeschaltet bild reporter matthias
becker matthias steht jetzt in dem
waldstück wo es zu dieser vergewaltigung
gekommen ist wie ist der momentane
ermittlungsstand ja die polizei hat
umfangreiches videomaterial auf der
tankstelle sichergestellt kurz vor der
tat war dort das opfer und hat sich noch
kurz etwas gekauft
viereinhalb stunden sagte uns der
pächter insgesamt sichergestellt worden
die polizei hoffte dass darauf
vielleicht die täter auch zu sehen sind
die davor oder am abend irgendwie auch
dort vielleicht was gekauft haben ich
war dort und habe angeguckt das sind
fünf kameras die den gesamten vor
bereich der tankstelle beinhalten dazu
kommt man hat die kleidung des opfers
sichergestellt und man hat natürlich
noch stur und soweit es noch möglich ist
im krankenhaus an dem opfer selbst
sichern können
bild konnte jetzt auch mit der mutter
des opfers sprechen wie geht es ihrer
tochter ja schlecht die tochter ist nach
hause gekommen und hat angefangen sich
erstmal zu waschen
die mutter sagte dass sie das alles
loswerden wollte
sie hat kann sich diese schrecklichen
zeit verdrängt ist auch sehr stark die
mutter betonte aber dass es egal ist ob
es nur ein deutscher gemacht hat oder
ausländer waren es ist völlig egal
es geht hier um die tat die tochter hat
nachdem sie sich entkleidet hat hat man
gesehen
hämatome und schürfwunden am ganzen
körper sagt die mutter
in derselben nacht kam es zu einem
weiteren missbrauchsfall auch im porzer
mann am s bahnhof soll es da irgendeinen
zusammenhang geben
die polizei glaubt nicht dass es sich
hierbei um dieselben täter handelt
der modus operandi die vorgehensweise zu
dritt alleine die beschreibung all das
zeigt oder davon geht die polizei aus
dass es unabhängig von den taten
unterschiedliche täter waren